[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros
comenzamos en 5 minutos con nos acompaña
maría teresa zegada analista política
socióloga y politóloga boliviana señora
llegada muchas gracias por esta
comunicación estas son unas elecciones
que muchos señalan como las más
importantes de la historia democrática
de bolivia usted coincide por qué
exactamente mire estamos de pronto a dos
días de realizar una de las elecciones
más críticas yo diría de todo el periodo
democrático porque estas elecciones en
realidad son una repetición de
elecciones que fueron anuladas el año
pasado y desde esa elección hasta este
momento o sea se ha distinguido un
escenario muy crítico en el país no
solamente por la polarización política
que hay entre dos bloques y en realidad
uno constituido por el movimiento al
socialismo que está buscando su retorno
al poder en bolivia y por otro lado
oposición a este movimiento al
socialismo que está realmente ado en
varias opciones políticas pero sobre
todo con un candidato que está
articulando en este momento la oposición
como
a la anterior elección fue sin nada por
él por un fraude electoral en este
momento hay bastante susceptibilidad de
la ciudadanía respecto a cómo se van a
realizar estos comicios el órgano
electoral está renovado y acompañado por
organismos internacionales y tratando de
garantizar las mejores condiciones
posibles para garantizar que esta
elección sea realmente creíble y
transparente entonces los bolivianos
estamos realmente con una expectativa
muy grande en que esta elección pueda
atenuar y solucionar los grandes
problemas sociales y políticos que hay
en este momento en el país meses
históricos ha vivido boliviano siga
rezagada denuncias de fraude por unos de
golpes de estado por otros bolivianos
una presidenta interina acusada de
intentar perpetuarse en el poder
evo morales- en argentina dos intentos
frustrados de ir a votar con una
pandemia de por medio qué escenario se
analiza pueden abrirse de este proceso
electoral absolutamente atípico habrá
segunda vuelta
mire lo primero que estamos pretendiendo
que suceda con esta elección es que los
resultados sean acatados por todas las
fuerzas políticas como le digo el órgano
electoral está haciendo todos los
esfuerzos y la población va a estar
vigilante a cómo se realice este proceso
y esperamos realmente que se cumpla con
estas exigencias mínimas de garantías y
que podamos tener un resultado electoral
al día siguiente de la elección el
siguiente escenario será seguramente un
escenario parlamentario con las puertas
divididas porque tenemos como le digo
dos bloques que tienen una
representación importante en el país y
que van a ocupar escaños parlamentarios
entonces se requerirá en este segundo
escenario que estas fuerzas políticas
logren acuerdos porque necesitamos
enfrentar las grandes consecuencias de
la pandemia de la crisis económica que
se ha cernido en bolivia en estos
últimos meses y también necesitamos
atenuar los escenarios de conflictividad
social y política estamos buscando que
la elección sea el escenario democrático
para resolver este conjunto de
controversias como
y las condiciones y las garantías para
un proceso transparente lo que esperamos
es que las fuerzas políticas respeten
ese resultado y puedan conformar estas
alianzas para resolver los problemas más
críticos de bolivia soy ahora cegada
cree que el más tras la salida de evo
morales es ahora lo suficientemente
fuerte para retomar el poder en bolivia
mira el más ha mantenido durante este
año eso lo dicen las encuestas
electorales alrededor de un 30 por
ciento del electorado duro es decir un
núcleo que vota por el movimiento al
socialismo que este este electorado es
bajo en relación a elecciones anteriores
por ejemplo el 2014 este partido sacó
más del 60 por ciento de votos pero
mantiene un electorado importante las
fuerzas opositoras por su parte tienen
una digamos un desempeño electoral
alrededor del 40 60 por ciento lo que
nos llama la atención en bolivia es que
a estas alturas hay alrededor de un 20
por ciento del electorado está
indeciso en su votación y por la por la
cercanía de la primera y la segunda
fuerza política ese 20 20 por ciento en
electores indecisos con seguridad va a
definir el derrotero de las urnas el
próximo débil muy bien pues muchas
gracias por esta comunicación maría
teresa zegada ella es analista política
socióloga y politóloga boliviana y
muchas gracias ustedes por su compañía
los recordamos la información no se
detiene con actualizaciones constantes
no sólo aquí en nuestra señal televisiva
sino también información al momento en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom que
disfrute de su día
[Música]